sounds like no
hey my name is kaya hi my name is Alex
I'm Scot Berman hey guys I'm tayo I
started working at McDonald's when I was
about 18 I worked at McDonald's from
February 2018 July 2018 I used to work
at McDonald's from my junior year to my
senior year in high school I worked at
McDonald's at the tender age of 14 years
old like any job there's always gonna be
some horror stories you always have
something crazy that happens okay so one
shift I came in a little bit earlier
they had me on the front desk doing
cashier when you're doing cashier you
sometimes sweep and mop up front and
that's what I was doing so I was over by
the juice and the soda bar and there was
this guy there just chilling I'm pretty
sure he was homeless he started talking
to me I don't mind when they talk to me
at all but he kind of got weird with it
I was like hey I want to tell you my
life story basically so he started to
tell me the hated art sold everything
left his girl just to do like everything
went downhill I'm not sure why but I
don't like him so I was like oh that's
cool I wanted to do art too and I wanted
to do music as well he was like oh I can
show you the way if you come with me
somewhere what does that even mean
so I kind of got freaked out I went
behind the counter and I was like hey
he's kind of freaking me out I'm pretty
sure he's hitting on me kind of don't
want to get right can you tell him to
leave so he came up to the counter and
he whispered something a little and it
was like he proceeded to lean in him
like his to me almost was like this it
was like I was like you know so my
manager got really mad she was like you
need to leave this is a minor you need
to leave I'm calling the police and so
she called the police and he got banned
this is regarding one specific customer
I'm gonna call him Rob for right now he
had been coming there since before I was
working there and he would come in the
store opened and he would leave 30
minutes after we were supposed to close
he made us basically keep the store open
and some reason everyone else complied
with him to be honest I think everyone
was a little bit scared of him the thing
with Rob was he would usually grab
receipts from either
or people's trays or the trash fill out
like the little survey on the receipts
and give it to us for free food
one day we caught him on camera doing
that he told him no that could all be
kind of forgivable because he seemed to
be a bit down on his luck but he would
actually come in and on his laptop we
actually caught him watching porn near
the play area multiple times and then
once we told him no he would just go in
the bathroom for a while and then come
back other than watching porn yet the
play area he would always be cussing on
the phone cussing at his laptop cussing
at us because the Wi-Fi was slow we kept
telling the managers like we need him
out he's a terrible customer he's barely
a customer he's creating a really harsh
work environment for us and the
customers it all came to a head one day
when he was cussing you're at a family
with little kids so the table were like
nah you're out you're out of here my
favorite part about having him gone was
the time he tried to sneak back in the
drive-thru line we took his order we ran
back out to see if that was really him
we let him wait about 20 minutes in the
lines it was rush hour and then when he
got to the window were like we're sorry
you're Ben he was extremely mad and he
cussed all the way out of the drive-thru
and yeah that was a story of Rob I hope
I never run into him again we all hope
that because he was honestly a really
big jerk one time there was this guy he
was a little on the larger aside which
is perfectly fine
every Tuesday it was twenty nine cent he
was either hamburgers or cheeseburgers
but 29 cent burgers this rather large
man came in and we asked what would you
like and he ordered the burgers and we
said how many would you like
and he said all of them well there was
this like hot I wasn't sure how to react
when somebody said all of them basically
what he wanted to order was every single
burger that we had in the restaurant
called the manager and I was like what
is what do i do how do we you ring up
every burger in the restaurant I think
we topped it off at about a hundred and
so we literally just rang them up gave
it to him in multiple bags to this day
we're about 90% sure he ate all of them
in the parking lot
it was it was on Sunday late afternoon
early evening I remember being at the
register Sunday's was typically when
they put all that schedule for the
workweek but I remember my coworker
coming in that day walking into the back
and all I heard was just what dog just
being upset at their schedule and it
hours being cut she got really all you
hear in the background was why would you
do that what the business like what
would you cut my hours let this person
just starts like flipping burgers over
maybe flippin fries over everybody in
the front we just kept all looking at
each other like is this really happening
llama cows is the greatest place in the
history of the universe there's always
gonna be some horror stories I was one
of the craziest nights at the time
that's my heart and crazy story and
having a crazy co-worker my experience
was actually decent at least for a first
job and especially for a first job at a
fast food place I do have some horror
stories
[Music]